this next story is so crazy
we're gonna have to bring in Fox News
contributor Raymond Arroyo to explain
this whole crappy story that he has for
us so what's the new job in San
Francisco or him thanks a lot I'm glad
you bring me on for this Jason but this
story is really unbelievable
there are over 7500 homeless people on
the streets of San Francisco well they
have now deployed with the San Francisco
Chronicle is describing as a poop Patrol
their one mission and they're getting
paid a hundred and eighty five thousand
dollars a person there one on the
streets how much money how much money
one hundred and eighty five thousand
dollars a person Jason all they do is
pick up poop now there's another patrol
force seven hundred thousand dollars
they spend on them all those four people
do are pick up needles from the street I
mean this is a breakdown and I will put
up on the screen the full screen of the
72 million dollars San Francisco is
spending just to clean up its streets
this is what's called making a truce
with illegalities they have there's no
penalty for homelessness they don't
enforce the laws and public urination is
legal look at this twelve million
dollars for homeless encampment housing
okay just to clean it up 2.8 million to
wash down biohazard material and 3.1
million for pit stop portable toilets
and Jason just to give you some sense of
what the poor people of San Francisco
are going through the San Francisco
authorities receive 70 calls a day from
complaints about individuals leaving
human waste in public areas this is a
disgraceful situation in more ways than
one it really needs clean up both
politically and otherwise no I mean it's
sad when you've got a homeless situation
I don't want it to minimize that at all
but to pay somebody a hundred and eighty
five thousand dollars to clean up the
human waste
that's unbelievable right you've got to
enforce the law I've built build another
homeless shelter and teach people basic
hygiene but to just let this go all no
they're not solving the problems their
liberal policies are not solving the
problems
exactly I want to get your reaction to
another story Steven Tyler he was
evidently a longtime acquaintance of the
president he's demanding the president
Trump stop playing Aerosmith music at
his rallies what's happening here that's
right well they're acquaintances the
Steven Tyler has worked for the
president at mar-a-lago
at Trump Tower at other events he was
just here in New Orleans as a matter of
fact where I'm coming from tonight
Steven Tyler was at Jazz Fest he was
warm he went out to people he sang at
bars in town people loved him but he's
not showing the love to Donald Trump
these days he has sent three cease and
desist letters to the president saying
we don't want to hear you playing
Aerosmith's music anymore here he is to
Joe Rogan listen to this he calls me up
and I said Donald you can't use dream on
as for causes not campaigns and he did
anyway he did anyway and I had to sue
look at Deena is who sent him a letter
of cease and desist so I've been through
that hmm you know the curious thing here
is I mean you can enforce copyright and
that's what Stephen Tyler says he's
doing and forcing copyright he says it's
for good causes not for politics but I
don't know how you can stop the public
dissemination of music if you're paying
basic ASCAP fees you should be able to
play that music wherever you want
whether it's at a political rally or in
a public park or a restaurant so I don't
quite know how this is going to shake
out but Steve entirely keeps making a
lot of noise about this and the
president seems to be telling him
dream on yeah but finally another story
out of Hollywood this one is off this I
I knew a movie celebrating I hear murder
what what in the world is done enough
Brian
Hanson who is Jim Henson's son has
created a new movie called the happy
time murders it's not just about murder
it's an r-rated feature featuring
puppets that look an awful lot like the
Muppets you and I grew up with okay I
can't even show you clips from this
movie I'll show you this little bit of
the trailer just watch this hey Ansem
looking for some rotten cotton I'm a
woman you
that's okay it's even got a good time
for you yeah you know remember Stadler
Walt Walden and Stadler the two at
Waldorf and staffed were the two Muppets
this antibody to the old Muppet Show
they used to say it's like a kind of
torture to have to watch the show that's
how I feel about this happy time murders
movie coming up there are sexual scenes
I mean Muppets having intercourse is not
something I wouldn't even think about
but this movie is filled with this stuff
and you know Jason I sit back
Disney tried this last year when they
rebooted a show called The Muppets and
it was trying to restart the Muppet
franchise but it was also off-color a
little raunchy and Randy it didn't work
people rejected it why Brian Hanson now
thinks a feature will work with filthy
Muppets getting killed slaughtered and
having sex I don't know it would be a
little bit like the Disney daughter's
taking Mickey and Minnie and creating
animated pornography with them you don't
do this you're ruining childhood
memories and you're destroying a lovable
sweet family brand that you really could
have a big future with and I think
running it into the gutter know it
listen great stuff thanks for sharing it
with this but you're right they're
ruining your brand in destroying
memories of kids like me and some others
that had fond memories of the Muppets
that's that's too bad I agree leave
Fozzie Bear alone and let him have his
clothes on exactly